-This is a wonderful jacket.
I want to just start by saying.
This is my -- listen, this --
I may never wear another thing.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-I lost it, you know.
-I did know.
What happened?
-You saw it on the --
I -- I got so --
I was at the airport,
and I left it or dropped it
or someone took it.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-You know people will.
-I know how they do it, yeah.
-They see a jacket
and go, "Ooh."
[ Laughter ]
"Got to have it."
And they could be big and --
but quicker than me.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-So I put it on Instagram.
-That you lost it?
-Luckily, I had a thousand
pictures of it.
-Uh-huh.
-And so I posted a picture
and said,
"I lost my jacket in
Minneapolis/St. Paul airport."
That's my hometown.
-Woo-hoo!
-Yeah.
-Yeah, give it up
for Minneapolis.
-Glad to see you got out here.
[ Laughter ]
And I didn't get any response.
And then I said,
"Maybe I'll just call
the lost and found there."
Which don't -- You know how that
is, calling the lost and found.
-Yeah.
-You never get through.
Boom, guy picks up, John.
I go, "Hey."
"Hey."
[ Laughter ]
You picked up.
I turned into Romney there
for a second.
Hey!
And I go, "Do you have --
Can you check to see
if you have a giant --"
[ Laughter ]
What is the name of
that stuff they call it?
There's a name for it.
Anyways, I think I said
herringbone which is wrong,
but jacket.
And he comes back and he goes,
"We got a big blue checked one."
[ Laughter ]
I said, "Will you send it?"
This was, like, Thursday.
-Yeah.
-I said,
"Will you FedEx it to me?
Because I'm on Seth's show --
-Oh, yeah.
-Monday and I'd like to
wear it."
-And they did.
-And he did.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I think his name
was Don Gubosch.
-Don Gubosch.
Look there you are.
You're so happy.
-Yeah.
-There's the FedEx box
and everything.
-You know, cause you need --
Nowadays, when you're going on
social media, you need a story.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-It's obviously -- I'd just
gotten back from the new "Solo."
My "Star Wars" shirt.
-Gotcha.
-And I opened the package.
And what was in it?
Of course, that jacket.
It's obvious.
-No, it's like --
-It's all wrinkled.
-It's like a three-act play.
[ Laughter ]
-Happiness is that I am
on Seth Meyers' show.
-With your jacket.
-With my jacket!
[ Cheers and applause ]
And Fred is back!
-Fred's back.
-Yeah!
-What is --
You're on a newer tour.
What is the name of
your new tour?
-"Big Underwear" tour.
-The "Big Underwear" tour.
How do you come up --
how do you name your tour
the "Big Underwear" tour?
-I was washing my clothes.
[ Laughter ]
Which I don't normally do.
But when you're on the road,
you've got to do things.
And I fold-- so I put them
in the dryer.
And then I was folding them.
And I took out the underwear.
And I went, "Jesus."
[ Laughter ]
I did.
It was an involuntary "Jesus."
[ Laughter ]
Like I go, "Jesus!"
And I'm looking around
for someone to tell.
And no one was there.
I go, "Are these mine?!"
[ Laughter ]
"Are these mine?! No!"
'Cause you don't know
how big your underwear on
while you're -- are while you're
putting them on.
I got ahead of myself.
-Yeah.
-But you don't know.
And then I go, "My God."
-Yeah.
-And so I said,
"I'm not -- I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna do a tour called
'Big Underwear' tour."
[ Laughter ]
'Cause I'm an underwear hoarder.
I don't know if you know that.
-What are we talking? A total --
-Six big boxes when I cleaned
out my storage of big underwear.
-Wow.
[ Laughter ]
-From different decades.
-Oh, wow.
-'80s, '90s.
-So you've never --
And looking back,
has the style changed a lot
over the last four decades?
[ Laughter ]
-Well, yeah.
The '80s, they were carefree.
[ Laughter ]
The '90s, ew.
And, you know, just --
yeah, they were.
You know, I was a poor kid.
So I always think
I'm out of underwear.
-Oh, okay.
-And that's why I had them all.
-Yeah.
-No one wants them either.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, have you tried to
give them away?
-Yeah, Goodwill won't.
They shame you.
-They shamed you at Goodwill?
-Yeah.
They go, "It's unsanitary."
I go, "They're clean!"
They were clean.
-They won't take them?
-No.
So I make artwork
out of them now.
[ Laughter ]
-So you -- obviously,
you play a mom,
on "Baskets",
which is fantastic.
It's a fantastic portrayal.
-Thank you.
-And did that inspire you
then to write this book
about your mom?
-Yes. I came home one day.
I was working on the show
with all my good friends.
There's Zach Galifianakis
and Jonathan Krisel
and Martha Kelly.
And I was overwhelmed.
And I was thinking about my mom.
Because I'm really
playing a mom.
I'm not playing Louie Anderson
as a mom.
-You're really not.
-I'm not.
I'm telling you,
some weird thing happens to me
where I disappear.
It just does.
Anyway, I can't explain it.
Wish I could.
So I wrote, "Dear Mom,"
and I wrote this long letter.
And I sent it to a couple people
because it mattered to me,
the letter.
And they -- they were --
both said,
my good friend Abraham and my
manager Amos, and they said
this would make a good book.
And I said, "Ugh, that seems
like a lot of work."
[ Laughter ]
-Your mom seemed to be quite
a character,
especially at restaurants.
What was your mom like
at restaurants?
-Well, she didn't --
any Midwesterner,
if they aren't waited on within
15 seconds, they do this.
[ Laughter ]
"Is there anybody else here?"
It's true.
Honestly, my mom's first words
were always,
"Could we get
some extra butter?"
And the maitre d' would say,
"Well, let us seat
your party first."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-It's really a lovely book.
-Thank you.
-And she seemed like
a lovely woman.
And it really is truly,
for my money,
one of the great portrayals
on television.
And I'm so glad
you're still doing it.
And thank you so much
for being back.
It's just always so great
to see you.